you and guess what while Twitter could
have been working on reinforcing its
security
what were they instead doing we're
launching words in Joad that were was
offensive and yeah that was offensive
and blocking people that were talking
about things they didn't want talked
about you know you want to know what
I've noticed but when it comes to this
critical race theory social justice
stuff but how come it how come it's all
of their arguments are literally just
the bonds of a functioning society
that's a good point
so destroy the family right the things
they target time schedules that's that's
racist that's whiteness destroy those
societies that list the white culture
list yeah I talked about it it's
annoying because these things aren't
even white culture yeah it's not like it
bothers me I'm like you think people in
China don't have time right that you
think people in Japan didn't have
schedules for farming
I think communists don't don't pay
attention to the time of the day the
time of the male's you know plant food -
that's who I am eat I think the the
degree to which we've been infiltrated
is worse than anyone imagines I agree
with you take a look at this tweet
Christopher F Ruffo
let's see who's this guy's the director
of Discovery Institute Center on wealth
and poverty said critical race Theory is
spreading rapidly through the federal
government last week a whistleblower
sent me a trove of documents about a
divisive diversity training at the
Treasury Department what I discovered is
deeply disturbing and an affront to
equality and buckle up the training is
called difficult conversations about
race and calls on white employees at
Treasury Federal Reserve FDIC CFPB and
NCUA a UC NCUA to pledge a lie ship amid
the George Floyd tragedy the goal is
explicit to convert everyone in the
federal government to anti racism he
then goes through all these details
which I'm not going to read because I
think most people understand you know
the claim they claim the expression we
should be more colorblind and where
we've made so much progress in the 60s
are in fact racist statements so we get
this this is in the Federal Reserve the
Treasury the FDIC CFPB and CUA the
degree to which this fractured and
demented ideology is
writing throughout our armed forces our
corporations and our federal government
is alarming I agree and it's worse than
we realize what you need to understand
is it's not a question of equality it's
I don't know it's not a question of
racism the things that they claim are
racist schedules time being accountable
for your actions yeah I want to hear
that I have it sitting here I'm happy to
read it oh here being accountable for
your actions is just that just blew me
away the scientific method objective
rational linear thinking
cause-and-effect relationships working
hard working hard to being the key to
success what isn't that so condescending
yeah serious absolutely it's ridiculous
like all right I got it oh yeah all
right sorry about that this is what is
infecting our federal government at the
highest levels citizens are financial
institutions they say the family
structure is white culture that you have
internalized these are the things
they're saying we must get rid of when
they say abolish whiteness or whatever
and we see journalists let me tell you
story maybe I should should I call these
people out I think so
how are we gonna get in trouble I don't
want to start no no no I'm gonna don't
do it then when I works for fusion one
of the highest-ranking individuals had a
Twitter banner that said something like
abolish whiteness MA and you have to
really look into that suit that means
what does that mean it means no family
structure no husband no wife in the
homemaker children children should have
their own rooms and be independent
object no scientific method history they
say the history is based on on Europe
and everything yes we have history and
those who forget their history are
doomed to repeat it Oh Protestant work
ethic work ethic is whiteness hard work
is the key to success
they say that's whiteness must be
abolished work before this is in our
federal government these these these
diversity and inclusion initiatives are
a Trojan horse okay because we already
believe in these things we already have
laws guaranteeing these things since
1964 ah
they said it's racist we're getting to
that point I wouldn't be surprised if
this this whole stream gets taken down
for us even talking about this
you know look at this they say religion
these are these are things they want get
rid of time follow rigid time schedules
time is viewed as a commodity wealth
equals worth your job is who you are
respect Authority really only only white
people do that and this is a part of
what they're teaching in schools
apparently there's that they have units
in the in the in the militant in the
military and they're trying to convert
convert everyone in the federal
government to these things now I don't
necessarily believe upon reading these
things that the goal is actually to
create a cohesive ideology for which
people will follow for any any real
means it looks like they're trying to
destroy the bonds of a functioning
society time following a schedule what
would happen if no one showed up for
meetings on time
there'd be no meetings that's correct so
I'm gonna show up at 9:00 and say
where's everybody nobody shows up until
9:00 50s you know nine ten comes out the
guy leaves nine fifteen someone shows up
who cares
following a time schedule well that's
whiteness we abolished that work ethic
hard work equals is the key to success
imagine if no one did any hard work and
they sat around though that would be the
end of humanity as we know it except
there are still many people around the
world to engage in hard work that's true
so if you want to destroy a country
these are the kind of ideas you need to
instill in their people get them really
angry tell them stop working hard stop
following schedules they can rotate O's
look at this and potatoes this is and
this is fake to aesthetics based on
European culture steak and potatoes
bland is best do you know the East India
Trading Company was all about spices
spices yeah
spices the wars were literally fought to
make food taste good exactly this is
fake so they're there they're trying to
look at this a sex man's attractiveness
based on economic status power and
intellect these are things that make a
society function and not just ours
what's that mean competition be number
one win at all costs winner slash loser
to comedy no oh my goodness this is
action orientation master and control
nature must always do something about a
situation instead
what what is the opposite of that their
little things about a situation don't do
it don't work hard don't follow
schedules and if something bad happens
don't do anything don't respect
authority don't make any decisions
decision-making Yelp decision so don't
make any decisions Wow
this is the Sidious it is instant love
absolutely and creeping transformation
destroying the bonds of a functioning
society yeah this is a every single
thing on here is solid it's like what
what does it have to be what does this
have to do with being white and what
they're going right nothing there's
nothing that has to do with you know
white you know why what I told this
story I pretty sure to you before when I
was at the Dakota access pipeline
protests and go and this guy was telling
me that time oh yeah colonial mm-hmm
to tell me that my my you know family
that came from Korea yeah were unaware
of the concept of scheduling a meeting
right oh but oh but that's because white
people brought that that's not true you
didn't make up time
right these people believe white people
invented times that is super demeaning
these people are extremely racist
absolutely 100% this is from white
supremacists that's what it seems like
when you say that hard work is whiteness
yeah that's ridiculous they are that is
white supremacy absolutely that is
straight out of the mouths of the Klan
it's crazy
yep I I don't understand how we're here
right now and what do you think happens
when people in our federal government
all started hearing to this stuff I
don't know yeah so the bonds have been
weakened by people like Alyssa Milano
who tweet print money print money yep
someone who says print just print money
has no idea what they're talking about
comics at all as as we're facing say
this major hack you know now that I
think things are getting resolved how
easy it would be to disrupt and destroy
and we're on the we're on the verge of a
serious international crisis catastrophe
world war whatever gonna call it China's
encroaching in the South China Sea
they're threatening us the threatening
Taiwan they have concentration camps so
in India
threatening India I read about I read
about them taking over a Russian city a
Russian city yep what happened with that
there they they claim they had a it was
originally Chinese land and because of a
treaty in like 1910 or something like
that China Russia got got this city and
then over time and I guess they they
said now that treaty is null and void
we're taking it like how is that not why
I wish I had to pulled up I don't have
it but from God from what I remember
what I read that's what was it all over
again men yeah concentration camps the
stealing of land they claim is history
is ancestrally there's yeah and now it's
a direct confrontation with us I wonder
why it is that we've known for some time
now about the concentration camps that
they're taking the the we're Muslims and
harvesting their organs and hair and
selling them yeah and nothing has been
done by anybody now we've done sanctions
I didn't hear about it until I came here
and you told me about it you know it's
like no one's talking about that there's
no news they're more concerned about
whiteness in the federal government
right
I feel like this stuff you know what
that is that's the Bitcoin of this
twitter twitter ness get everyone
thinking about this while everything
else is happening look at the big point
look at the Bitcoin while we're
undermining everything look at this
there's whiteness racism while they're
undermining everything and that is what
we need to pay attention to the racism
is not prevalent yes there's racists of
course they're probably always will be
you know look at Nick Cannon what he was
saying that's racist that dude went off
the rail he did but you know what
freedom of speech in this country yep
you know okay fine say it I think you
might think you're an a-hole for saying
all that stuff you only got fired from
one gig he still has like a bunch of
other hosting jobs nobody cares yeah he
said things that I can't repeat I can't
believe I heard someone say that
nowadays and he he's spouting Farrakhan
and it's like I've looked into him and
he's crazy and scares me that people are
actually following the ideology it's
like look man if I were if I were to be
conspiratorial right now mmm-hmm it
seems like China has been trying to you
know you know how you want you what you
want to do the dishes right you can't
just go in and wash the dish you got to
soak the dishes you got a soak them
because all that that cheese is all
stuck to the bottom
I can't get out you try to take a knife
you're scraping it but not you just ruin
in the pan wait hold on are you trying
to say that America is the food stuck on
on dishes right now America and China's
trying to do the dishes and am I giving
that analogy is that china is soaking
instead of just going with a heart
attack right they've allowed this
ideology to be bolstered and fester well
tell you what though --if out it doesn't
feel like a lot of American citizens are
softer nowadays various and then people
who stand up and have a strong spine
sold canceled yo are you talking against
canceled get rid of it we can't have
people thinking that they can be strong
but they can have a strong mind and have
critical thinking no no no no let's not
let's not have people idolize strong
fingers let's let's have that don't
think wither away you you have you have
about like 11 or 12 percent of the CDC
demanding the CDC declare a public
health crisis due to racism they can't
they can't do that it's not possible
they cannot do that because right it's
it's not a function of their I mean it's
I'm talking I'm talking about what Ram
the ramifications oh what that would
mean if I thought you meant it was like
not bureaucratically possible to make a
decline I don't know I don't know if
maybe they can but but you know what you
know what would happen cannot do it
though you know what happened if that
was the case though if they if the CDC
said okay man all of a sudden you will
find yourself one day they're burning
they're burning the Declaration of
Independence
probably it was made by white slave
owners to defend their slave aqua see
you don't defend that it also greatly of
everyman equal yeah you know it's like
that's what they want to get rid of
people don't understand how serious this
is when you have a large portion of
various federal government agencies that
have become zombified you know so maybe
maybe it's not just war with China maybe
it's both civil war and war with China
maybe the goal would be that if a war
with China breaks out they trigger some
kind of internal conflict so that we
destroy ourselves well the only way
they'd win doesn't that make sense
doesn't that seem like the exact thing
that they would want to do and I will
say it again the things listed in this
whiteness white culture thing are
literally just the bonds of a
functioning society yeah exactly work
hierarchy time schedules that is not
unique to white people self-reliant
self-reliance like have you ever watched
anime you know like an anime an anime
character is superhero comics whatever
they all teach these things it's
cross-cultural you know being number one
winning when hierarchy being polite yep
yep
make sure hey not showing emotions like
I show my emotions proudly avoiding
conflict avoid conflict yeah into
intimacy intimacy is a white thing look
at this written tradition how dare you
this is not anything with white they're
literally saying if you if you want to
end racism you need to stop avoiding
conflict yep whoa whoa whoa so what we
should go around fighting each other if
you want to end racism you need to start
showing your emotion be angry they say
on Twitter all the time yeah you telling
me to calm down is white supremacy it is
non having a civil conversation as is
white supremacy a good man but but how
else do they get people to stand behind
this stuff I don't know they say Cranham
Adam you're not racist are you you want
to end white supremacy don't you of
course he doesn't work everybody does
it's horrible well let me show you the
list yep there it is
intent protecting property protecting
your property is white supremacy wow
that sounds pretty communist I had a
conversation earlier with some local guy
and I told them about what happened in
st. Louis and I said I said I've been
warning people man and I mean this
seriously a mob of 300 to 500 people
show up to a private community sign say
no trespassing they apparently broke a
lock entered at some point someone broke
the gate the people who live in the
house who saw these people enter their
private property on their property
brandished weapons I don't mean that
negative sense like they pull out their
guns and said get off our property they
were on their own property it was
private property that was gated a mob of
people broken you know threatened them
and this is a castle doctrine state what
law did they break
I don't know well it sure what ended up
happening was the protesters came back
and then the police came back
served a warrant and seized the rifle
from this homeowner who in a castle
doctrine state stood his ground on his
property when people broke into his
private property why did the police go
after him I am Telling You this now when
the mob comes to your house so many
people just cannot understand this and
I've been saying it for a long time it
will not be a bunch of anti faloona
ticks bang on your door threatening you
it's gonna be a bunch of lunatics in the
street screaming the police will come to
your door knock and say I'm really sorry
to do this but you're under arrest for
what we got a warrant for what doesn't
matter I'm just doing my job the people
in st. Louis the McCluskey's were
attacked you know legally defended
themselves and the police went after
them so what do you think happens when
the financial institutions are now
overrun with these zombified cultists
that's scary to think about it
absolutely scary to think about you'll
find your bank account frozen your
insurance not paid out your bank your
MasterCard gets cancelled you get
terminated from all Internet services
you are cancelled out right you know and
you can do nothing about it and it's in
government so right now some people
think well at least you know we're still
equal under the law and that's what
comes next the financial institutions
have already banned people there are
many people who are banned from owning
credit cards and from using them and
people in their in their homes you know
there's many people have been banned
from speaking out social media and now
we're learning the federal government
has these people coming you know so then
what's gonna happen is oh there there
will be a law that says you know you are
FDIC insured your bank account for
whatever reason you know it went under
and we're gonna ensure that cash in
there and you're gonna show up and and
the person working in the government
cyndago oh it's you you're not bigoted
are you says here online you've been
cancelled bye-bye but I'm legally
entitled to I don't care yeah
but-but-but my money that the I don't
care because you're a racist and what
happens at the CDC declares a public
health emergency and then you actually
have some kind of weird CDC enforcement
of well time is white supremacy it
just destroying the bonds and walking us
down towards the cliff to jump off you
know meanwhile we've got serious
conflict brewing with China and people
keep saying you know you know what's
what it's a bit irked some China is a
paper tiger they can't do anything
they're too weak they'll never win we're
not gonna be fighting a war we're you
know a bunch of u-boats or whatever
crashed into the shores of China or
something or Taiwan right or where
Chinese boats crashing the shores of Los
Angeles we're gonna be fighting a
social-media war where private
information and financial details get
leaked what would happen if China say XL
traded banking information and published
all of it every credit card every
username and password of every bank
account it's a frightening premise it
would be like if they hope if there was
one big bank that everyone you know went
to in this country just one and all the
money was in it and then one day they
just blew it up and all the money was
just laying there everybody would just
run in tower grabbing whatever they
could if they published every name and
username of banking accounts and I
believe they do you think they have the
capability to do so especially after
this you know random people will just
log in and start taking your mere money
and you'd have nothing everyone have
nothing it would just be the end it
scary or your private details your
private information your your your
private messages yeah the bonds of
society would fracture yes it would be a
cyberattack I mean they could they can
hit our our power source they can hit I
mean that that that especially you know
like we would lose if we lost power and
everything just shut down and we
couldn't get it back up because they
took over and put in some malware that
just destroyed everything yeah
cyberattacks are serious business yes it
is scary business you know for the
longest time we haven't had any really
good cyber capability systems right I
remember
so I there's a couple hacker conventions
Def Con and blackhat and I've seen
demonstrations where they're like oh
here's how you blow it blow up an oil
oil refinery and they just like types in
line of code and press ENTER then you
watch the thing do a demonstration where
it's like nope there goes there was one
I watched where they actually popped a
valve like they burst the pipes Wow they
forced two pumps to go in the wrong
direction and burst a pipe it's that
simple
and and they were like we can mount the
the you know a device on a drone the
drone could get within radio radio range
and we could transmit that
wirelessly and then young man yep thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune into
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you